hey what is up guys my name is a Jenner
and welcome to the third episode of my
morning coffee series today we're going
to cover the rest of the numeric
variables long float and double now
we're getting into variables that are to
put simply huge the long variable
contains an integer that has the minimum
value of negative 9.2 quintillion and a
maximum value of 9.2 quintillion in
order to use the declared integer as a
long and L is appended to the end of the
Declaration but wait if you think that's
huge wait till you see the next to float
is the first number variable so far to
be able to contain decimal values it
contains anything from negative 1 point
4 e negative 45 to roughly 3.4 e38 a
number that is 39 digits long floaters
mainly used only when its standard which
is usually not very often OpenGL and
similar graphics library is mainly use
floats for calculations and rendering to
indicate a float being declared the
letter F is usually inserted at the end
of the Declaration simply putting a
decimal point and a digit at the end
indicates that the format is a double
not a float which is why the f is needed
double is the last number variable on
our list and it's absolutely huge it
ranges from negative 4.9 e- 324 to about
1.79 a 308 yeah that's right maximum
value being 309 digits long if you come
up with a number larger than that that
you wish to use let me know Oh point
zero or a decimal point must be inserted
into a double declaration to ensure that
it's used as a double not an integer
thanks for watching and I hope you
enjoyed this episode of morning coffee
I'll be back tomorrow covering the rest
of the variables in Java car the lien
and string until then goodbye